[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL NEWSON: I'll introduce
myself a little bit.
As the slide says, my
name's Paul Newson.
I go by the title SRE Advocate.
I feel the need to explain
that because to my knowledge,
I'm the first person
to ever call themselves
an SRE Advocate.
We have this thing at Google
called the developer advocate
which is somebody,
an engineer who
works in developer relations
who goes out and talks
to developers and interfaces
with the developer community.
I like to do that
same thing but I
like to do it with
SRE and DevOps folks.
And I recently did a
mission control rotation.
That's a thing at
Google where you
get to embed yourself
with an SRE team
and walk in their shoes
and carry the pager
and live an SRE's life for
between 6 and 12 months.
It was a fantastic experience.
I was really fortunate to
have the chance to do it.
And now I'm here to
hopefully share with you
some of the things
I learned along
the way about designing
reliable systems with Cloud
infrastructure.
So if we're going to talk about
designing reliable systems,
I do want to get really precise
about what we mean by reliable.
So when you look up the word
reliable, what you get is this.
There's some good words in here.
Consistently good in
quality or performance,
sounds kind of like
what we're going for.
But I actually think the
more insightful phrase here
is able to be trusted.
Because what it comes down
to, if your users trust
your system, then your
system is reliable.
If you have earned that trust,
then your system is reliable.
If your users don't
trust your service,
then your service
is not reliable.
And that's going to be different
depending on your service.
So let's take this
system for example.
The reliability required
for this particular system
for those users looking
at those windows
at the top of the space
shuttle is very, very high
for them to trust the system.
Compare that with, for example,
an entertainment service.
Users still want to
trust this system
and reliability is
still very important,
but I think it's pretty clear
that the level of reliability
required by a life
safety critical system
and the level of reliability
required by an entertainment
system to earn the users'
trust is different.
And that's because
the consequence
of a brief temporary outage of
the system is very different.
In one case, you
don't get to play
your game for a few minutes.
In another case, it may
endanger somebody's life.
So, we've talked
a bit about trust.
Your goal is to get your
users to trust your service.
Trust is context dependent.
It's different for life
safety versus entertainment
versus financial versus
retail versus whatever
it is your systems do.
And the last point I
want to make about trust
is that it's really
hard to measure.
In fact, I don't know
how to measure trust.
Maybe there's a psychologist
in the audience today
who knows how to measure
trust and can approach me
after the session and
tell me all about it
and that would be a great
conversation I'd love to have.
But the engineer currently
standing on the stage
doesn't know how
to measure trust.
Moreover, I have no idea
how you would measure
trust in a real time way to see
if your service is currently
delivering on that
goal of user trust.
So we need to find a proxy.
We need to find
something we know
how to measure which is a
proxy for that user's trust.
And this brings us to the
concept of a service level
indicator.
The SRE book says, a carefully
defined quantitative measure
of some aspect of the level
of service that is provided.
So basically, it's something you
can measure about your service.
In this particular example,
I've got a graph here.
It's showing an
error percentage.
So this particular service
that I pulled this graph from
is a fairly straightforward
HTTP request response
kind of service.
And this graph is showing us
the percentage of requests which
resulted in a 500 class error.
It is very unlikely you can
read the scale on the left,
but it's not that important.
The important thing is
you look at these spikes
on the left of the graph
and you're like wow,
those look pretty scary.
Are they a problem?
Maybe, maybe not.
It really depends
on your service.
So what transforms a
service level indicator
into a service level
objective is adding a goal.
Now this is where we have
to look at the things
we know how to measure
and use the insight
that we have about
the services we offer
to decide what is
a threshold that
makes sense for this
service level indicator.
So again, let's go
back to this example
where we have this HTTP
request response pattern.
And in this particular
case, let's say
this service is something where
every HTTP request can easily
be retried if it fails.
In that case three nines might
be perfectly adequate to--
a perfectly adequate threshold
to set as your service level
objective.
Because if someone gets
a 500 class response,
they can retry the request
and they'll get a success.
And the client will
probably do it for them
and the user will never
know that a 500 was served.
In other words, below
99.9% success rate,
user trust is not eroded.
Now this is not a
universal thing.
It depends on the service.
And this is where we
get to apply our user
empathy and our
engineering judgment
to choosing these objectives.
So in this case--
I know it's very difficult
to read this slide,
but those spikes don't
even come close to 0.1%.
In fact, they're one order
of magnitude below that.
So these spikes in this case,
as scary as they may look,
are no problem at all.
The last point I'd like to
make before moving on from this
is to talk about service
level agreements.
A lot of people use
the term service
level objective
and service level
agreement interchangeably.
And I think it's very
important to tease these two
things apart.
A service level agreement is
a contract with your users.
It is a legally binding contract
between a service provider
and a customer.
Quite often an SLA will contain
an SLO embedded inside it.
But usually, that SLO--
which some might refer
to as an external SLO,
the SLO you're offering
to your customers--
is different from
the internal solo
SLO you actually use
to manage your system.
And generally, the internal SLO
will be stricter than the one
that you put in your service
level agreement or SLA.
So just to recap, an SLI
is something you measure.
An SLO is an SLI plus a goal.
And an SLA or service
level agreement
is an SLO or service level
objective with penalties.
So I could do a
whole talk on just
how to do this really well and
give lots and lots of examples
but that'll have to
wait for another day.
I'd like to move on to the
concept of an error budget.
The error budget is related
to your service level
objective or SLO.
If you take, say, a three nines
SLO and then ask the question,
well how often can I be down,
that gives you a 0.1% error
budget.
It's really the same thing.
It's just that sometimes
your error budget
is easier to reason about.
For example, if you're
running a three nines service,
that means you get
43 minutes a month
where you get to be down before
you have violated your SLO.
If you're running a
four nines service,
that drops down to
4.3 minutes a month.
So you can see how this
sort of makes it real
when you think about how
long of a global total outage
can I have before I
have violated my SLO?
And if you look in the
five nines column here,
you can see it's pretty tough.
You get 25.9 seconds
a month before you
have violated your SLO.
That's a pretty high bar.
Quite often as you move
to more nines in your SLO,
you also increase
the time window
over which you measure that.
So you might measure it over
90 days or a whole year,
for example.
So if we look at five
nines over a year,
you're looking at
about five minutes
of a total global outage before
you have violated your SLO.
So, that's not a
whole lot of time.
That sort of sets
the bar pretty high.
How do you go about that?
Let's say, for example, that
you have an on call rotation
and your agreement
with your on callers
is that they should be hands
on keyboard troubleshooting
the problem five minutes
after the pager goes off.
You've just used up your entire
SLO budget, your entire error
budget for the year
waiting for your on caller
to put his hands on-- his or
her hands on the keyboard.
In this case, type faster is
probably not the right answer
for how to stay within
your error budget.
Instead what you need to do is
apply lots of best practices
to your service to keep the
humans ahead of the service.
To make total global
outages, which
will consume all of your
error budget incredibly
quickly, very, very,
very, very, very rare.
The book is a great start,
I'll plug the book a few times.
I can't say enough
good things about it.
You have no excuse
not to read it.
If you go to this URL,
you can read it for free.
It's out there under a
Creative Commons license.
There will be a book signing up
in the fifth nine lounge area.
I don't know when.
But if you go up to the fifth
nine, it should be posted.
And you get a chance to meet
some of the authors as well.
And I think they're
giving away maybe 100
copies to the first
100 people up there.
So go check out the fifth nine.
So, how does an error
budget help you?
Well, it helps guide
decision making process
about a lot of different things.
Any time you change
your service,
there's a certain
amount of risk involved
in that and a certain amount of
effort in making that change.
So for example, should we
deploy this new feature?
Well there's risk in
deploying the new feature.
There's effort in
There is clearly effort
in making the new feature.
Should we deploy it now?
Well, look at your SLO,
look at your error budget
have you consumed all of
your budget for this month?
If the answer is yes,
you should probably wait.
Give your users a break,
deploy that next month.
How should we trade off resource
usage versus reliability?
For example, and we'll see some
examples later in the talk,
you can over
provision your service
to make it more reliable
but that adds to your cost.
Is that a worthwhile investment
or can you run a little hotter?
The answer to that will
be in your error budgets.
If you are consuming all
of your error budget,
you probably don't
want to run any hotter.
If you're not consuming
all of your error budget,
maybe you should
consider running
your service a little hotter.
We've got developers who
can write awesome things.
Should they be writing
awesome new features
or should they be
writing code which makes
the service more reliable?
How do you choose
between these two things?
They're both great.
Well again, look at
your error budgets.
Are you consuming all of your
error budget every month,
month after month?
Well you should probably be
investing a little bit more
in reliability to keep ahead
of the growth of your service.
If you're well within your error
budget, bring on the features
because you're meeting
your SLO easily.
Here's a good one, should
we do more testing?
Testing's good.
Testing is always good, right?
Again, look at
your error budgets
month after month after month.
If you are consistently
putting out releases and not
causing outages
and not consuming
your error budgets, whatever
testing you're doing
is good enough.
And testing more is only going
to add cost that provides
no value to your users.
On the other hand,
if your releases
are not super reliable,
if they cause outages,
if they're not
going out reliably
and are quite often rolled
back, maybe investing
in testing infrastructure
is exactly what
you should be doing.
But I'm not here to talk about
any of those things today.
I'm here to talk
about architecture.
How do you architect
your system to minimize
total global outages?
And how do you trade off
the cost of doing so?
How do you know
whether you should
invest in the cost of doing so?
And of course it comes back to
your service level objective.
How can I design my service
to meet its service level
objectives with minimum cost?
So the particular type of--
the particular aspect
of architecture
I'm going to spend a
lot of time on today
is how do you use our
instances, zones, regions,
and multi-regions to
assemble a resilient system?
And this is going to be the
focus of the talk today.
So first thing up is instances.
This is our most
granular building block
on the Google Cloud platform.
This is a virtual
machine running
in one of our data centers.
Not surprisingly, it runs
on a physical machine.
Also not surprisingly,
there are bad things
that can happen to
physical machines
and you're probably all
familiar with these things.
DRAM can go bad.
NICs can go bad.
Power can fail.
You can have operating system
bugs which crash the machine.
If the physical instance
dies unexpectedly,
then your virtual
instance goes with it.
Probably no big surprise there.
There are also bad
things that can
happen to the rack as a whole.
The power to the rack can fail.
The networking can
fail at the rack level.
Again, any of these things
happen, your instance
is going to go with it.
Again, probably no
big surprise there.
Now, if you're managing 10
machines or 100 machines
these kind of failures
are actually quite rare.
But when your scale goes up to
thousands or tens of thousands
of machines, the
rare becomes common.
And Google and
other companies that
have been running large
fleets of machines
have learned that handling
reliability and software
is more flexible and more cost
effective than handling it
in hardware.
So the reason I'm
not up here talking
about how we have the world's
most reliable hardware
is because these
things are generally
handled at the software layer.
That has advantages in that
software is much easier
to change and
improve on over time,
but it also allows you to
choose different service level
objectives for different
services running
on the same hardware platforms.
But let's get back
to your instance.
Something bad happened.
The physical machine
failed unexpectedly.
What happens to your instance?
Well, we start it on some
other physical machine
automatically for you,
unless you've told us not to.
But wait, you might be asking.
What about the stuff that
was on my hard drives?
Well if you're storing your
stuff in persistent disks,
though that data is already
stored in a distributed
fashion throughout the
cluster, which means
we can still mount
your drives even
though we're running on a
different physical machine.
The exception to
this is local SSD
which as the name
implies is in fact
local to the physical
machine you are running on.
So in a scenario like this,
those disks are ephemeral.
Now, you need to be aware
of that so you choose--
you use them appropriately.
Some great uses I've
seen for these things
are as caches because if the
cache goes away, well great,
you'll just refill
it somewhere else.
I've seen it use
really effectively
for other sort of
cache like things
like shuffle space for large
high performance MapReduce
jobs.
And I've also heard of
people running open source
databases which can span
across multiple machines
and doing that effectively
with local SSD.
So let's talk about
the difference
between planned and
unplanned failures.
Occasionally we need to do stuff
to the machines in our data
centers or to the racks
in our data centers.
This would be
planned maintenance.
This is different
than what we've
been talking about before.
The big difference here
is we know it's coming
and we can use
our live migration
feature to get your instance
out of the way of the planned
maintenance.
So basically, this stuff
is invisible to you.
And that's true
even for local SSD.
We're transferring the
contents of the RAM
of your virtual machine
from one instance
to-- from one physical
machine to another already,
we can do the same for the
bytes on the local SSD.
Now I've spent a
lot of time talking
about how instances fail and I
don't want this to scare you.
I mean, it's a fact of life.
We all have run hardware, we all
have had computers fail on us.
The computers in Google's
data center are no different.
But we understand that if
your experience on our Cloud
platform was that
my instances are
having unplanned
failures all the time,
we would lose your trust.
So not surprisingly,
we have an internal SLO
around how much of that is
acceptable before we need
to do things to mitigate it.
And what that means
is in aggregate
over lots of instances,
most instances
will have the opportunity
to live a long, healthy life
if that's what they want to do.
That doesn't mean any
individual instance can't
suffer an unplanned outage.
But over a large
number of instances,
you'll probably find it does
not happen often enough to erode
your trust of the service.
And that's us choosing an SLO
with user empathy for you.
So now we've talked
about instances.
Let's step one
level up to zones.
Instances live in zones.
Zones roughly
correspond to a cluster.
Now the word cluster
is a very vague term
and has different
meanings depending
on who you're talking to.
In this context, a
cluster is basically
an extremely well
connected set of computers.
If you've read the paper we
wrote about our Jupiter cluster
level networking, that's
what we're talking about.
You're all in one big
happy Jupiter family
and you can talk very low
latency, very high bandwidth
to each other.
So if your SLO
requires more then
you can expect from
a single instance,
the solution is to run
on multiple instances
within the zone.
Now if any one instance fails,
the rest can pick up the load.
We have an HTTP or
SSL load balancer
that you can put in
front of your instances
to spread the traffic
across those instances that
will detect the failure
and direct traffic
to the healthy instances.
You can use open source
frameworks like Kubernetes,
open source databases,
for example HBase,
to spread your data and
your stateless processing
across an entire zone.
So we also have
hosted products which
do the same thing for you but
with less overhead for you.
Container Engine is a
hosted Kubernetes solution.
Cloud Bigtable is
the same Bigtable
we wrote the paper
about ages ago.
It's available to you
as a hosted service.
Cloud Dataflow lets you run
your Apache beam workloads
across an entire--
in a distributed
fashion across an entire zone.
And Cloud Dataproc
does the same thing
for Hadoop and Spark workloads.
So great, we're done, right?
We're running across a
bunch of machines in a zone.
All of those bad things I
talked about that can happen
to your instances, you're fine.
Well, not quite.
There are still things that
are shared by all the machines
running in a cluster or zone.
For example, they all
share that Jupiter network
I was talking about.
They at some level
share different pieces
of the power hierarchy which
feeds power to all this.
And they're all in the
same physical building.
So if there's a fire
in that building,
it's going to affect more than
just one instance at a time.
On the software side, the
cluster level operating system
which we've published some
information about called Borg
or the cluster level distributed
file system, which we've also
published some information
about called Colossus,
they can have--
if they get unhealthy
at a cluster level,
that's going to affect more
than one instance at a time.
So we call all of these
things correlated failures,
failures that affect
or problems that
affect more than one instance
in a zone at the same time
because the failure mode is
related to the zone or cluster,
not to the--
something bad happening to
the individual instance.
So how do we address this?
Well, enter regions.
So a region is what we
tend to call roughly
speaking a campus in Google.
You can think of it as a
set of buildings hosting
Google clusters that are
in close physical proximity
to each other.
This photo here is
of our data center
campus in The Dalles,
Oregon, right there
on the Columbia River.
This is home to our
US West One region.
So you can see a couple
of buildings in here.
Regions share less
things than zones.
They are on different
networking fabrics.
They're running independent
Borg cluster operating system
instances.
They're running separate
distributed storage systems.
So a lot of the
failure modes I talked
about where you could
get a correlated failure
within a zone will not
happen to a region at a time.
Additionally, we take pains
to manage our software
in such a way that
if we're going
to perform an upgrade, for
example to the Borg operating
system in one zone,
we're not simultaneously
doing that in another zone.
So that if there is a problem,
we have time to detect it
and it's only going to
affect one zone at a time.
So we try as hard as
we can to restrict
these correlated failures
to a single zone.
However, physically
close is good
because we can
provide lots and lots
of low latency, high bandwidth
between the zones in a region.
But physically close
is also kind of bad
because for some extremely
rare forms of failure,
they may be correlated
to an entire region.
So for example,
earthquakes would kind of
affect a region all at
once or hurricanes might
affect a region all at once.
And in one particular
made up case,
we had a region
attacked by zombies.
No, it's not real.
We do this thing called DIRT.
You can see it on
the slide there.
You can go read about
this in the ACMQ.
But basically, we do
these disaster readiness
tests all the time at Google.
So while we haven't actually
suffered a regional failure,
we practice things
like that to make
sure we know we can handle it
if the situation comes along.
So how do you protect against
these extremely rare but still
possible regional
scoped problems?
Well, we have one
the one region.
So kind of the same solution.
When the zone wasn't giving
you enough reliability
to meet your SLO and you stepped
up to running in a region,
multiple zones in a
region, if a single region
isn't going to give you enough
resilience to meet your SLO,
then you can step up and
run in multiple regions.
And again, the
HTTP load balancer
is perfectly happy to balance
your traffic across instances
in multiple regions just like it
could do it in multiple loads.
And that works great for
stateless servers, request
response servers.
But what about your
persistence layers?
What about your storage?
What about your messaging?
How do you run those
across regions?
Well, , it's a hard problem
but Google offers some services
in that persistent layer that
already run in what we call
multi-regions.
So a multi-region is generally--
we have three right now, United
States, Europe, and Asia.
These services run
in multiple campuses
across these broad
geographical areas
so they are not vulnerable
to single region failures.
We currently have
Cloud Storage, which
provides multi-region support,
Cloud Datastore, which also
and Cloud Pub/Sub, which is
a persistent messaging service.
So these are automatically
spread across regions.
So if you let Google worry
about your persistence layers
using one of these
services, then all you
have left to worry about
are your stateless servers,
whatever they may be.
And as we've talked
about before,
you put those behind one
of our HTTP load balancers
and you can have that traffic
spread across multiple regions.
I'm going to spend some
time digging deeper
into that particular thing.
So I'm going to
start with a fairly--
a very oversimplified
version of this.
Here we have a
representation of a service.
It's running across 10 instances
in two different zones in two
different regions.
So it's now a
multi-regional service.
So it's insulated from
individual instance failures,
it's insulated
from zone failures,
and it's insulated
from regional failures.
In this case, what the
numbers mean here is
each server can only handle
100 requests per second
before becoming overloaded.
So I've colored them
yellow to represent hey,
these are maxed out.
They're good but
they're maxed out.
And then I carry that
yellow up to show hey,
we got 500 requests coming
into US East One, 500 coming
into Europe West One, and
1000 coming into the service
globally.
So now what happens if, say,
US East One B goes down on us?
We have one of these
correlated failures.
Now what?
Well the load balancer will
detect that the instances
are no longer healthy.
It will stop sending
traffic there
and all that traffic will be
directed at Europe West One.
Well, now we're overloaded.
Now we're asking each server to
provide 200 requests per second
or 200% of what it's capable of
doing without being overloaded.
I'd like to put an aside in here
and say it's a really good idea
to test how your service
behaves when it's overloaded.
Because no matter
how much you try,
sometimes things
are going to happen
which is going to put your
service into a little bit
or a lot of overload
and it's really nice
if your service degrades
somewhat gracefully
in those situations versus
a total global failure.
But how do we get out
of this bad situation?
Well, we stand up
five new instances
in the zone that's
still good and we're
back to being able to serve
without being overloaded.
Now depending on your SLO, you
could use humans to do this.
When your service
gets overloaded,
you hopefully have a service
level indicator for that.
It goes over a threshold,
a human gets paged.
Five minutes later,
they're at their keyboard
saying, wow we're
really overloaded.
I'm going to spin
up new instances
to take up this slack.
You could do it
that way but you can
see that putting a human in the
loop there adds a lot of time.
You're overloaded for longer.
Now maybe that's
fine for your SLO,
depending on how many
nines you're shooting for.
If it's not, you can use
robots to do this for you.
Specifically, we have
something called an autoscaler.
And you can use that
with Container Engine,
you can use that with something
called Managed Instance
Groups where you
essentially tell it, hey,
each instance can take
100 requests per second.
So when you see
1,000 coming in here,
please spin up to 10 instances.
So this solution has-- even
this over simplified version
of the solution still
has two problems.
The first problem is
you are putting yourself
in a situation where
when there is a failure,
you will have
temporary overload.
So that's problem one.
Problem two is what if you can't
spin up five more instances
in that replacement zone?
What?
If you submit those
requests and it says sorry,
we couldn't bring up
instances for you.
And now you're back in overload
and you're kind of stuck there.
So why would this happen?
Well, this is where I have
to talk about stockouts.
I know it may appear that
we have infinite capacity
but the truth of the
matter is we don't.
And to explain that, I want to
talk about banks for a minute.
So banks maintain this
wonderful illusion
that I can walk up at any
time and say give me my money.
And as long as everybody who
is a customer of that bank
or a significant
percentage of them
doesn't walk up at
exactly the same time
and ask for most or all
of their money, it's fine.
Because they keep a
certain amount of cash
in reserve so that when
you walk up to the bank,
they're able to
give you your cash.
So they keep this
reserve around.
So Cloud capacity is
kind of like that.
We keep an inventory around
such that most of the time
if you come up to us and say,
hey, I need five instances,
we're like great, here you go.
Here's five instances.
And as long as the
requests-- we add customers
at sort of a normal
rate and those customers
grow their services at
sort of a normal rate,
we can keep ahead of that.
We're really good at
keeping ahead of that
and providing this illusion
of infinite capacity
so that every time you ask
for five more instances,
we're like, fantastic,
here you go.
However, if we get a very,
very large inorganic,
unpredicted spike, we could
consume our inventory.
Now we're going to add
inventory as quickly as we can.
It's not like a bank run
where a bank actually fails
and then everybody
loses their money.
We're just going to start adding
inventory as quickly as we can.
But this inorganic
demand spike may
cause this temporary
stockout situation.
What could cause such
an inorganic spike
in demand in a particular cell?
What if we had a cell
failure and everybody
is fleeing from the
cell that's no longer
there into other cells?
That kind of sounds like an
unexpected inorganic spike
in traffic.
Everybody suddenly
wants more capacity,
or some fraction of our
customers wants more capacity.
So how do you protect
yourself against this?
Well the simple solution is ask
for the instances in advance.
So in this particular
case, what I'm showing here
is we have five instances
in each zone which
are serving the traffic and
we have five spare instances
in each zone.
Now, this is grossly
oversimplified
because load balancers are
really good, not surprisingly,
at balancing loads
so really, you
get this where all
the instances are
at 50% capacity instead
of some maxed out
and some doing nothing.
Now when the zone fails,
the traffic just spills over
and now we're at 100%
capacity in the zone that's
already there.
You are no longer exposed
to a stockout risk
because you already have
the instances you need.
And you don't get a temporary
overload because you already
had the capacity spun up.
However, it costs you double.
You're running 20 instances
now instead of the 10
that's required to
serve the traffic.
So can we do better than that?
What if we go across five zones?
So here, each zone is
responsible for dealing
with 200 requests per second and
we have three spare instances
in three of the zones.
Again, because load balancing,
it would really look like this.
The question is, why do we have
three spares instead of two?
We only need to
be able to soak up
200 extra requests per
second if a zone fails.
And the answer is because
the zone that fails
could be one that
has a spare in it.
So you have to be prepared
for any of your zones to fail.
So this is great.
Again, no overload,
no stockout risk,
but its only 30% overhead.
This is a huge improvement.
We've gone from 100%
overhead to 30% overhead.
Can we do even better?
If five zones was
good, why not 10?
So here, we only
have two spares.
Again, the spares
aren't really spares.
It would spread the
traffic out like this.
And now a failure of one
zone again just spills over.
This is great now.
We're at 20% overhead and
any one zone can fail.
But-- oh, this is what
we call n plus one.
Any one zone can
fail and we're fine.
So we have n plus
one reliability here.
But we've now opened ourselves
to a new failure mode.
Do you see it?
Let me give you a hint.
Hello again, Matthew.
So this is Hurricane Matthew.
Hurricane Matthew paid a visit
to South Carolina last October.
That also happens to be
where US East One is.
In the end we ran some
generators for a while
but there was no interruption to
service to any of our services.
But it's an interesting
thought experiment
to ask what if we had a
complete regional failure?
Are you insulated against that?
And in this case, that
takes out two zones.
So by adding a second
zone in each region,
we actually increased
our exposure
to the regional outage.
Because before, losing a
region or losing a zone
was the same thing.
Now they're different.
So in this case, we're
back in the same position
we were in before where
we're temporarily overloaded.
But you'll notice we're
like 10% to 12% overloaded.
It's not quite as catastrophic
a situation as it was before.
And we have eight places where
if we can bring up just one
instance in any of these eight
places, we're good again.
So the risk is a lot lower than
it was before when we were only
running in two zones.
But if that risk is not
acceptable given your SLO,
then we get back to a
situation where you're
going to run three spares.
So now you're at
30% overhead again,
and it kind of looks a lot
like the five zone solution.
But now we're almost at
what we would call n plus 2
where I can almost lose any
two zones and I'm still good.
It's only if I lose
two of the zones
with the spares in it
where I'm at a problem.
So running in 10
zones is better than
running in five because you
almost get to n plus 2 with 30%
overhead whereas before.
You were only at n plus
one with 30% overhead.
So there has been
an improvement.
So one of the simplifying
things-- assumptions I've made
is this notion that
we have exactly 1,000
requests per second flowing
in all day, every day.
Every day is the same and
we can statically choose
how many servers we have.
Of course that's not
how most services are.
Let's pretend we
have a service that
has [INAUDIBLE] cycle where
1,000 is the trough and 2,000
is the peak.
So let's look at what it
looks like at the peak.
And let's expand our
footprint into Asia Northeast.
Now we're running in 12 zones.
And let's make all
the zones the same.
If we run three
instances per region,
we don't quite have
enough capacity
and if we run four
instances per region,
it looks like we're
wasting capacity
because all these things
are running in the mid 80s.
And the overhead
here is about 20%.
We're running 24
instances when 20
is all that should
be required to serve
2000 requests per second.
That 20% overhead kind
of sounds familiar.
That's where we ended up before.
Now if we lose a single
zone, life's not too bad.
A bunch of it can failover
within the region,
which is good.
And then the rest can
sort of spill over
to the other regions which
are not running super hot.
And if we lose two zones,
whether it's in a region
or across two
regions, it doesn't
matter because all the
zones are now the same size.
That's kind of cool.
And we can lose two zones and
we are now running at 100%.
No overload, no stockout risk.
That was for the peak of 2000.
So basically with 20% overhead
running across 12 zones,
we've now got to n plus
two, a true n plus two.
We can lose any two zones.
So that was the peak.
But for the trough, if we
stick with our static two
instances per zone, now we're
vastly over provisioned.
Like, we're running
down in the 40%.
This is a huge waste of--
is not a reliability problem.
Clearly we can withstand all
kinds of failures right now.
But it is a cost problem.
If only there was
something that would
scale the number of servers
automatically to the amount
of load that was coming in.
But of course there is,
I mentioned it earlier.
We can use managed instance
groups or our Container engine
to do that for us.
So what if it's scaled
down to one instance?
Now we're in this
situation where
we have one instance per zone
and we're still at n plus two.
So life looks pretty good.
So the autoscaler
can save you money
by reducing your number of
instances during your troughs.
And if you configure
it with some slacks,
so you sort of say, hey I want
to run around 80% utilization,
then if you suffer a
failure, that 20% becomes
where that traffic goes
in the case of a failure.
So now we're back to our 2000.
Life is good again.
The other simplifying
assumption I've made here,
you'll notice that our
traffic is beautifully
spread absolutely evenly
throughout all of our regions.
If only the world
could do this for us.
It's never going
to be like that.
Your traffic comes
from everywhere.
You don't get to pick where
your traffic comes from.
So for most-- for many services,
the offered traffic kind of
follows the sun
because it's based
on humans being awake and
doing things with computers.
And you want to serve
as close as you can
to the people who are
submitting requests to you.
You don't want to send
the request halfway
around the world if
you can avoid it.
So a fairly typical
service might
have a peak around 1700 UTC.
That's the evening
in Europe and it's
the morning on the
West Coast and it's
the middle of the day on the
east coast of North America.
So that's when some services
sort of have their peak.
So let's pretend
that we're doing that
and we have kind
of this pattern.
With our static two servers, two
instances per zone, what we see
is we're offering a lot
more traffic in Europe
than it can handle so it kind
of spills over to US East which
is now spilling over to
US Central which is now
spilling over to US West One.
It works.
We're not overloaded.
All the requests get served.
But we're not serving
them as close to our users
as we might like which
means they're probably
seeing additional latency.
And if we lose Europe West One,
it's going to get kind of ugly
at that point.
We're going to be
doing a lot spilling.
So instead, what if we use
our autoscaler and we say,
hey, run as many services as
you need to keep under 80%.
You're going to end up with
something that looks like this.
And there's some overhead here.
We're running 27 instances total
when you should only need 20.
But it's all in--
it's all region, which
means you're giving your
users a better experience.
You're serving them
closer to where they live.
And you've got a lot of spare
capacity kicking around here.
So if you lose one of your
big zones, a lot of that slack
can be taken up
in region and then
there's a little bit of
spill over to another region.
But of course you have an
autoscaler on these things.
So those instances that are
now running at higher than 80%
are going to feed back
to the autoscaler.
Hey by the way, I'm above
80% and the autoscaler
is going to say,
well gee, I better
bring up some more capacity.
In the end, you should
converge to something
like this where the traffic
is being offered in region
and the four instances we
lost from the failed zone
get brought up automatically
in the same-- in another zone
in the same region.
Wouldn't it be nice
if we didn't have
to worry about zones though?
We thought so too.
So if you like the autoscaler
and you like that idea,
we've got this thing called
a Regional Managed Instance
Group.
And basically what
it says is, hey,
run me some instances in
these zones in these regions
and I don't care that much
about what zones they're in.
Just make sure I've got
enough in each region.
So it takes us from
here where we're
caring about what zone things
are in to this mental model
where we're only caring
about what regions are in.
So, I talked a lot
about the autoscaler.
If you want to know more
about that, if that sounds
like something you
could use, there's
going to be a talk tomorrow.
I encourage you to go see it
if that sounds like a tool
that you would like to
have in your toolbox.
So that was a lot of
slides on traffic spilling
here and traffic spilling
there and scaling
automatically and where
do you want to run it
and things like that.
There's a different path
if you want to take it
and that is App Engine.
App Engine is sort of our--
it has all of this
built in, so to speak.
You just give us
your code and we
run it and you get auto scaling
and you get the failover.
We're handling all these
things under the cover.
You give us your code and
your application runs.
So if that sounds
interesting to you,
I encourage you to check
out this talk which
is Writing Infinitely Scalable
and High Performance Apps
with App Engine.
And if you might be sitting
in the audience saying,
you know what, I checked that
out two to three years ago.
It didn't fit for
what I wanted to do.
I encourage you to check
out this talk which is,
You Can Run That on App Engine?
We've done a lot to
the service recently.
And if you have looked
at it in the past
but have not looked
at it recently,
you might find that it
fits what you need to do
a lot better than it used to.
So I'm not going to go
any more in-depth on that.
Go see these experts.
So a quick recap, what
have we talked about?
We talked about
reliability and trust
and how they're
related to each other.
We talked about service level
indicators, service level
objectives, service level
agreements, and error budgets.
We've gone through
instances, zones, regions,
and multi-regions.
We've talked about the bad
things that can happen to them.
And then we've talked
in great detail
about how to spread across
these zones and regions
and how to avoid
overload and stockouts.
So in a sense, what I've
done is I have exposed you
to what I think are some
really awesome tools
for building super
reliable systems.
Like, if you have
dig a hole, that's
going to dig you a
really good hole.
I'd like to use that.
That looks like fun.
But really sometimes, you
don't need a hole that big.
Sometimes a shovel will
do the job just fine.
So again, how do
you decide if you
want to use the
shovel or the backhoe?
You look at your
service level objective.
So here are my
rough rules of thumb
about when you need to go--
the backhoe is on the far right,
the shovel is on the far left.
If you're looking for less
than two nines of reliability,
you're probably going to be
just fine on a single instance.
You've got enough
error budget there
that if your instance
fails, you just--
you take your backups
which you have, right?
And you restore them on another
instance and off you go.
Or if everything is
already in persistent disk
and you've been
taking snapshots,
then it just comes
back up for you.
So that might be totally fine.
A zone fails.
Well, you might have to do some
manual stuff where you bring it
up in another zone, but
you've got enough time
in your error budget for
humans to take these actions.
So you don't need the
backhoe for that job.
If you want a couple of nines,
running in a single zone
should be perfectly adequate.
When you get up to
three nines, you
should be looking at
running in a single region.
If you want four
nines, now you need
to be spread across
multiple regions
if you really want
to achieve that.
Now, before I get to
the five nines case,
there's a very important
point I want to make.
This is sort of
the price of entry.
This is-- if you build on the
single zone, single region,
multiple regions,
you have the ability
to get two nines or three
nines or four nines.
But it's not a
guarantee depending
on what you put on top of it.
You need to manage your stuff
with reliability as well.
The number of nines
your customer sees
depends not just on
our infrastructure,
but also on your
part of the stack.
So this is guidance but it
doesn't mean you will get this
if you follow it.
Everything needs
to work together
to provide those nines
to your customers.
Which brings me to
the five nines case.
If you're looking
for five nines,
you should probably
be talking to CRE.
What's CRE?
CRE is Customer
Reliability Engineering.
So, it's what you get when
you take the principles
and lessons of SRE and apply
them towards customers.
It means Google SREs working
with your SRE or ops team
to achieve your desired
reliability goals.
If that sounds like
I'm quoting, I am.
we want to drive more nines
to our mutual customers.
You're running your
stuff on our stuff.
We want our mutual
customers to be happy.
Customer Reliability
Engineering is an effort
to make that happen.
If this sounds
interesting to you,
you should talk
to your sales rep
and they can start
that conversation.
Now if you'd like to learn
more about Customer Reliability
Engineering, there's
a talk for that.
This is a talk by Luke Stone.
Luke, is that you out there?
No, all right.
I thought Luke was
in the audience.
This is a talk by Luke Stone,
in fact, right after this.
Please add 30 minutes
to all of these times
because I didn't know the
keynote was going to run over.
So if you are interested
in learning more
about what a CRE
engagement looks like,
this is the talk for you.
And then Luke also has some war
stories to share from his time
as an SRE and as a director
of this CRE initiative.
So I encourage you
to go check those out
if this is interesting to you.
The last thing
I'll leave you with
is come drop by the
fifth nine lounge.
If you are interested
in reliability,
if you're the sort of person
who carries quote a pager,
come hang out.
Your tribe is there at the
fifth nine on the third floor.
There will be a book signing
as I mentioned earlier.
And there's lots of
Google SREs and CREs there
for you to chat with.
I plan to spend a
lot of time there so
if you think of something
you want to talk to me about
or you just want to tell
me where my talk was wrong,
come on up.
I'd love to hear it.
Thank you so much for
giving me your time today.
I really, really appreciate it.
I sincerely hope you
found this worthwhile.
[MUSIC PLAYING]